na meine Damen und Herren waren sie auch
so wahnsinnig gespannt auf die
ampelkabinettsklausur in Meseberg
Gruppentherapie ja selten so wichtig wie
diesmal denn die Ampel hat sich
bekanntlich verhakt bei über 30
streithemen so und wenn wir uns jetzt
mal ganz objektiv angucken was am Ende
hängen bleibt von der Klausur da ist es
tatsächlich nur diese eine Szene der
Kanzler fast in den Schnee und formt ein
Schneeball wie ja wie ein ganz normales
glückliches Kind
atemlose Spannung was passiert als
nächstes auf wen hat er ihn geworfen und
hat es Annalena Bernburg weh getan
fragen über Fragen also ich habe ein
Schneeball geworfen aber wie sich das
für ein Bundeskanzler gehört auf
jemanden
entschieden wurde in Meseberg nichts ja
das ist nicht viel ne es ist sogar wenig
aber zu eurer Beruhigung auf Schloss
Schreckenstein ging es auch gar nicht
ums Land eine zerstrittene Regierung
wollte sich endlich wieder lieb haben
das war der Sinn der Reise dafür hatten
sie kein Witz ein Psychologen eingeladen
der ihnen beibringen sollte wie man die
ampelpolitik besser verkauft also
optimistischer vor allem das das war der
Plan Olaf Scholz
der Chef Animateur im Club Meseberg
fordert wir brauchen in diesem Land mehr
Zuversicht
wenn das mal so gesagt hätte bei ihm
dort das natürlich Stunden wir werden
zunächst einmal darüber reden wie eine
Gesellschaft die so viel vor sich hat
zuversichtlich sein kann und bleiben
kann denn das ist die Grundlage dafür
dass man sich etwas zutraut übrigens
auch wenn das gelingt in einer Weise
dass viele für sich sagen sie sind dabei
sie sind Teil der Zukunft
meine Fresse als er den Satz fertig
hatte war der ganze Schnee Meseberg
schon wieder geschmolzen
und sagt ja nicht umsonst immer wenn
Scholz redet weint irgendwo ein
Germanist
immerhin gab es aber ein wirklich
schönes klausur-showprogramm z.B diese
Tanzperformance ihr zeigt die mittlere
Tänzerin gerade wie stark die Grünen
sich in der Ampel inhaltlich verbiegen
müssen
ach so das war Indien nicht Meseberg
schade schade natürlich hätte es
jenseits von Zuversicht und Schneebällen
durchaus Themen gegeben ja um genau zu
sein 33 ungelöste Streitfragen bei denen
es im Kern immer um Geld geht Christian
Lindner hat gestern die Verabschiedung
seines Haushalts Entwurfs auf
unbestimmte Zeit verschoben es ist sehr
ungewöhnlich so groß ist der Streit es
blöd total blöd dass sie in ihrem
Koalitionsvertrag keine Ausgaben
priorisiert haben der Vertrag ist im
Grunde wie so ein XXL Wunschzettel ja
nützt dir gar nichts ja Zoff ist jetzt
der Ampel Normalzustand z.B Zoff über
Heizung und das mitgekriegt Robert
Habeck befiehlt das bereits ab Januar 24
nur noch Heizungen verbaut werden die
mindestens zu 65% mit erneuerbaren
Energien betrieben werden
ja ist habe ich
habe klaut uns als der Grünen unsere Gas
und Ölheizung Panik in drei zwei das hat
viele heute geschockt
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck der
die Planwirtschaft zurück nach
Deutschland bringen will und das ist
eine riesen Problem anfangen möchte er
mit Ihrer Heizung es ist absolut
gefährlich an den Sturm der Entrüstung
natürlich wahnsinnig teuer um uns zu
erziehen
ja muss die Frage
die Frage ist wie kannst du uns das
antun Robert tatsächlich steht das mit
den Heizungen im Koalitionsvertrag
ursprünglich ab 2025 und dann haben sich
die ampelmusen vor einem Jahr gemeinsam
verständigt das möglichst auf 2024
vorzuziehen gemeinsam trotzdem tut die
FDP jetzt überrascht und empört was soll
das
genau wie ein Bild und Co ganz ehrlich
die haben doch wohl alle den Arsch offen
Heizung ist egal
fakt ist drei Viertel der Deutschen
Heizung laufen im Moment noch mit Öl
oder Gas aber die darf man ja auch
erstmal behalten ne oder
das deutsche Einfamilienhaus wir dachten
wir wären darin sicher aber dann kam er
[Musik]
steht vor deiner Tür
die Heizung Weg sie haben dir das
weggenommen und ein Geschlecht jetzt ist
deine Ölheizung drin
denn die Grünen hassen dich und wollen
dass du frierst
erneut mehr ohne Öl Street nachts
ja
das Problem ist ja in Deutschland sind
wir alle total für Klimaschutz bis er
konkret wird
dann nicht mehr tatsächlich dürften
vorhandene Gas und Ölheizungen
weiterlaufen aber klar für Besitzer von
älteren Immobilien wird Sonne neue
Wärmepumpe vermutlich teuer wenn man
überhaupt eine kriegt vom seltenen
Rohstoff Handwerk aber kannst du
Schweigen einzige realistische Option
wäre auf der Straße zufällig einen
Installateur sieht
muss direkt persönlich aktiv werden
und dann Ketten man den bei sich zu
Hause im Keller so lange an bis er eine
Wärmepumpe einbauen das ist
das ist wie misery von Stephen King nur
halt mit Wärmepumpe
ich will sagen da gibt es tatsächlich
noch eine Menge Fragezeichen in dieser
Angelegenheit auch ob das mit den
versprochenen Übergangsfristen und der
sozialen Abfederung wirklich noch klappt
in den verbleibenden neun Monaten das
ist im Prinzip übermorgen das ist gar
keine Frage dass wir in der Umsetzung
weil wir Untersuchungen Zeitdruck
Handeln natürlich die Wirklichkeit voll
anerkennen müssen oh guck mal wie nett
ja
er erkennt die Wirklichkeit an ist doch
toll ich sag mal wenn wir bis 2045
klimaneutral sein wollen wie ist das
Klimaschutzgesetz ausdrücklich verlangt
muss man auch im Bereich Wohnen
verantwortlich für mehr als ein Viertel
unserer co2-mission wohl regelrecht
was machen so schrecklich das klingt
diese Erkenntnis sickert hoffentlich
auch bald bei der FDP ein die inzwischen
achten Sie mal drauf aber nicht nur die
ampelblockiert sondern ganz Europa ja
vielen Dank Verkehrsminister Volker
Wissing also wahrscheinlich auch gelesen
ne die die Europäische Union einigt sich
mühsam über Monate auf das Verbrenner
aus ab 2035 und dann fordert der Volker
hier plötzlich eine Garantie dass auch
danach noch Verbrenner mit synthetischen
e-fuel zugelassen werden was aber noch
nicht mal die Autoindustrie will ja
natürlich klar natürlich kann es
einzelne Unternehmen geben die sagen wir
haben kein Interesse an der Produktion
bestimmter Antriebstechnologien das ist
der Industrie selbst überlassen verstehe
einzelne Unternehmen haben sagt er kein
Interesse an ivues wer hat denn
Interesse so laut ADAC jetzt keine
Umwelt NGO im engeren Sinne ist das ich
guck mal nach die Firma Porsche
[Gelächter]
anderen Hersteller sind genervt vom Höhe
und Hot der FDP und wollen lieber
Planungssicherheit e-fuels eine reine
gespensterdebatte
wozu das Ganze Geschiss wozu warum für
e-fuels kämpfen nur wegen Porsche warum
weil ich den den das Geräusch das
Motorgeräusch des Boxermotors Liebe weil
ich gerne
forciert durch den Verkehr gleite
dann will ich nichts gesagt
ne
gern gern fossiert geleitet sehe ich die
Frage natürlich zurück
sind in der Herstellung teuer viel zu
teuer und verbrauchen dabei ohne Ende
Strom
technologieoffenheit gut und schön aber
eine Partei die sonst immer auf den
Markt schwört sollte eigentlich rechnen
können es rechnet sich aber nicht
deswegen sieht man ja so verdammt wenig
Tankstellen auch wenn manche das
Gegenteil überhaupt gesagt dass man so
viel Ländern schon tanken kann können
Sie mir denn sagen in welchen Ländern
denn tatsächlich getankt wird
schauen Sie schauen Sie nur in die
europäische Nachbarstaaten jetzt fehlt
mir die Redezeit die alle aufzuführen
ja wirklich als du es gibt so viele
Länder ich kann sie hier gar nicht alle
nennen das Nania
Mordor
Fantasialand
ist unfassbar ist unfassbar die FDP
sabotiert ein ampelprojekt nach dem
anderen Verbrenner aus Tempolimit Kinder
Grundsicherung alles von der FDP
sabotiert noch wissen wir nicht wer
hinter der Sprengung von Nord Stream 2
steckt aber
nur als unverbindliche Arbeitshypothese
ich stelle hier nur Fragen meine Mutter
aber zurück zum Europa ausbremser Volker
Wissing der wird lustiger Zufall
tatsächlich ausgerechnet heute nach nur
etwas mehr als einem Jahr im Amt
feierlich aufgenommen in unsere berühmte
heute-show Hall of Fame der
Verkehrsminister ist hier direkt nebenan
ich gehe mal eben rüber zu Matthias
Matschke
hallo
unserer Hall of Fame Matthias wow ich
wusste das gar nicht dass wir hier so
einen Aufwand betreiben nur ja klar
dafür gibt es ja Rundfunkgebühren ne
liegen hier rum
ist auch eine Frage des Respekts und der
Dankbarkeit wenn man bedenkt was diese
Männer uns für Sendezeit geschenkt haben
guck mal alles Legend hier Peter bei
Tempo 130 schlafe ich einen Ramsauer
oder der Dobrind die ganzen berühmten
dobrind-zitate wie
aber auch
ja genau er hatte und in dieser Galerie
der geistigen Giganten hängt seit heute
völlig zu Recht der Volker ja aber
Matthias ist eine Hall of Fame spielt
der denn wirklich schon in der absoluten
Top Liga ja ja absolut absolut wollen
Sie direkt mal einen spitzen Witz hören
zu Volker wir sind gern Volker Wissing
ist ein sehr sehr guter Verkehrsminister
[Gelächter]
möchte neue Autobahn bauen denn eine
Studie aus seinem Haus sagt jetzt der
Güterverkehr wird bis 2050 umfasst die
Hälfte zunehmen mit dem Achtung LKW als
wichtigste Verkehrsmittel warum weil
unser Schienennetz
Moment wir haben über Jahrzehnte
Schienen vergammeln lassen und jetzt
kommt Wissing und sagt guck mal wie
Gammel ich die Schienen sind lass uns
mal lieber mehr auf LKW setzen und noch
mehr Straßen bauen oder vielleicht doch
mal Priorität Schiene ja das läuft ja
längst nur halte andersrum
60 von insgesamt 74 neu gebauten
Schienenkilometer 2022 dem Gegenüber
wächst der Straßennetz in Deutschland um
rund 10.000 km jedes Jahr ah 74 zu 10000
also ganz knapp
nur der olle Güterverkehr dafür gibt's
tolle Nachrichten von Deutschlandtag
kennst du kennst du in Deutschland Takt
da fährt dann zwischen den großen
Städten alle 30 Minuten Einzug pünktlich
toll Deutschland Takt nennt sich das und
den sollten wir eigentlich bis 2030
bekommen jetzt verspätet auch er sich um
40 Jahre für Deutschland traurige
Zeichen sie ganz ehrlich sagen ja
lächerlich was soll ich dazu sagen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
warte mal ich habe auch
na hoffentlich
2017 ist ein super Jahr um mit dem
deutschland-takt anzufangen erstens wird
Volker Wissing dann 100 und zweitens man
darf solche Bahnprojekte ja auch nicht
übers Knie brechen sehen Sie es doch mal
so schon in 47 Jahren geht's los das ist
jetzt das neue deutschlandtempo ja ganz
offensichtlich ist es das meine gute
deutschlandtakt ist eine
Gemeinschaftsproduktion der
Verkehrsminister der letzten Jahrzehnte
das Elend hat der Wissing nur geerbt und
doch wird er die Fackel weitertragen die
Fackel der Unpünktlichkeit also er wird
sie natürlich mit dem Auto weiterfahren
auf einer neugebauten Autobahn ja was
meinen sie so ich sag mal perspektivisch
hat der Volker vielleicht sogar das Zeug
der größte von allen zu werden
Vorsicht keine Blasphemie der größte ist
und bleibt der Mann
den wir hier mit einer 18 Meter hohen
große ewig haben
die Hunde
[Applaus]
es gibt nur einen angeschaut
ein weiterer auch sehr emotionaler
Streitpunkt in der Ampel ist Champ
Özdemir ist geplant ist Verbot von
Werbung für Dickmacher Produkte die sich
explizit an Kinder richtet ist ein
wichtiges Thema in die Folgekosten von
Übergewicht und Diabetes sind
tatsächlich enorme Gesellschaft ne aber
ob es da allerdings hilft Werbung für zu
fette süße oder salzige Sachen in TV und
Internet zu verbieten würde das helfen
schwer zu sagen ne
andererseits Kinder sind das Wertvollste
was wir haben ja
Immobilien Wertpapiere
das kommt schon auf die Kinder an
natürlich will uns die
Nahrungsmittelindustrie möglichst früh
an einen ja gewissen süße gerade in
unserem Futter gewöhnen damit wir
schnell zu Zucker Junkies werden es
wirkt ja im Gehirn wie eine Droge Zucker
dieser unfassbar billige Geschmacksgeber
wird genau deshalb Produkten beigemischt
wo man ihn gar nicht vermutet wie
Rotkohl oder Heringssalat zumal er dann
glaube ich Arbeit auf der Verpackung
nicht immer Zucker heißen muss kleiner
profitipp von mir alles was auf Hose
endet ist Zucker
Eselsbrücke frisst du was mit Hose
spannt ihr bald die Hose
so merke ich mir
Kinder sind ideale werbeopfer weil sie a
sprechen was offen aus wir sind unter
uns ein bisschen dumm sind
und B offenbar Reich Kinder sind als
Zielgruppe von Werbung so interessant
weil sie einerseits emotional sehr
leicht zu manipulieren sind andererseits
aber auch weil sie selber kaufkräftige
Konsumenten sind Kinder zwischen 4 und
13 Jahren haben gut drei Milliarden Euro
jährlich zur Verfügung was
ich muss sofort meine Söhne anrufen
und mich voll verarscht diese Bonzen
Mailbox war klar so 35 Kilo Zucker
frisst jeder von uns im Schnitt pro Jahr
35 Kilo übrigens unverändert seit
Jahrzehnten weil es eine Droge ist und
um zu beweisen wie diese Droge wirkt hat
das ZDF dieses aufwendige Experiment
durchgeführt Kinder lieben Eis denn Eis
ist süß was Kinder hingegen gar nicht
leiden können ist wenn man ihn was Süßes
wegnimmt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ehrlich das schießt mir direkt die Milch
ein meine Damen und Herren
warum
wie unnötig war das denn bitte ich weiß
doch auch so dass Kinder gerne Eis essen
experiment was kommt denn da als
nächstes
das große zdf-experiment was passiert
eigentlich wenn man einem süßen
Kleinkind volle Möhre einen Fußball ins
Gesicht schießt
die Antwort in ihrem ZDF mit dem zweiten
quält man besser
ja
wir haben halt ein Bildungsauftrag ne
natürlich laufen jetzt Werbebranche und
Medien Sturm gegen Özdemirs Pläne also
die Lobby nur das ZDF das ZDF findet
nicht schlimm das Werbeverbot für
ungesunde Kinderprodukte würde den
Sender echtes Zitat aus Mainz aufgrund
der soziodemografischen
zielgruppenstrukturen des ZDF nur in
geringem Ausmaß treffen
die charmante Art zu sagen bei uns läuft
nur Werbung für Treppenlifte
und gegen Blähungen
ach ja
Wischmeyer Siegburg der Bekloppten und
bescheuerten
wenn du als grüner alt-promi beim
ampelschrott Wichteln nur das
Landwirtschaftsministerium kriegst wie
Cem Özdemir musste um jede Schlagzeile
kämpfen trotzdem legst du dich mit den
renitenten Bauern besser nicht an die
Brettern wegen jedem Scheiß mit Trecker
nach Berlin dann schon lieber Kindern
was verbieten und nur eine niedliche
Demo mit Bobby Cars riskieren also
näherungsminister habe ich auch eine
Schutzverpflichtung auch und gerade
Kindern gegenüber und bei Kindern wird
das Spaß auf stimmt sobald Kinder kommen
hört der Spaß auf vor allem der untenrum
Spaß zwischen den Eltern und kaum sind
die Blagen da kannst du zugucken wie sie
immer fetter werden
champign glaubt weil sie Werbung gucken
Spots wo andere Kinder Süßkram fressen
statt Mutti Steckrüben Stühle so manches
Pausenbrot bleibt leider liegen
tschüss jetzt haben die Kinder schon
wieder ihre Pausenbrote liegen lassen
kein Wunder bei solchen pausenbroten
Kinder essen nur was ihnen schmeckt gib
ihm doch die Kindermilch mit Hindernisse
ja randvoll mit Fett und Zucker aber
wenigstens ohne Alkohol den mogelfraß
aus den 80ern kann man Kindern heute eh
nicht mehr andrehen wo jeder zweite
zwölfjährige schon selber food
influencer ist hallo Cem Ötzi willkommen
in der Gegenwart Kinder werden nicht
dick durch Werbung sondern weil einfach
alle Lebensmittel zu viel Zucker und
Fett enthalten in England gibt seine
Zuckersteuer und siehe da bei den brexit
Belgern landet weniger davon in der
Fanta
die Kinder in Deutschland die werden
immer dicker das kann jeder auf der
Straße selbst beobachten darum haben
alle dürren Mamis ja auch einen fetten
SUV um ihre dicken Kinder in die Schule
zu bringen das dünnste Brett dass man
als Politiker bohren kann ist Symbol
Politik die nichts kostet glaubt Özdemir
den wirklich dass sich der Adipositas
Zubehör handelt von dem bisschen
Werbeverbot die Bilanzen verhageln lässt
Kriege gibt es doch auch ohne
panzerwerbung und der Crack Dealer hängt
keine Plakate auf Menschen ändern ihr es
Verhalten durch prominente Vorbilder
also ich hätte wieder gerne das also
Spaghetti also sogar Bohnen
aber sollen unsere Kinder wirklich zu
einem salzlosen Würstchen heranwachsen
dann ist mir ein lebensbejahender
Stinkstiefel vielleicht doch lieber ich
weiß dass Schokolade dick macht und
trotzdem erst die unglaublich gerne
freue mich nur Schokolade möglichst mit
Vollmilch dazu und freue mich daran und
warum tue ich das weil ich es will
er ist menschenwille ist dein
Himmelreich und kocht ihm auf die Birne
weich ich wünsche allen Zuschauern
weiterhin guten Appetit aber
schaut euch gerne weitere Videos an und
abonniert den Kanal danke
oh nein eine Zeitschleife habt ihr etwa
nicht den Kanal abonniert Hilfe sofort
draufklicken oder ich bin hier für immer
schaut euch gerne weitere Videos an